Today's news is all about positivity.
And what better way to focus on the positive than an entire
newspaper dedicated to good news.
Yeah, that's right.
This is The Happy News.
A British publication dedicated to only good news
in the world, look how great this is.
I mean, come on.
I grew up with pages of magazines lining my walls
like wallpaper.
In fact, I actually make a zine.
It's true, I'm not just all words, I'm action.
So the news team that I work with,
they brought me this paper.
They put it to my attention because they know
that I'm obsessed with good news.
And now I'm obsessed with the woman who makes this.
I'm kinda convinced she's my British soul sister
and here to talk about her newspaper, The Happy News,
please welcome Emily Coxhead.
(audience applauding)
Hi.
I think that will be the best introduction I've ever had.
Oh my God, well, I could have gotten a lot more psycho
overboard, I kind of had to tame down because I've like,
I feel like we've been separated at birth, I really do.
I mean, you love happy news, I love happy news.
You have an amazing design blog with your boyfriend
that I totally love.
I was scouring the Instagram account and I just love
what you're putting out into the world.
That's something I really subscribe to, I did it.
I said it, that's right.
Can I ask you since I'm just meeting my soul sister
for the first time, why did you create The Happy News?
I don't know.
I was sort of struggling with my own mental health
and I think the two things that were impacting it
the most were social media and the news.
And I sort of began to realize that it was having that same
effect on far more people than I'd realized.
So when I started looking for the good
and then sharing the good things,
I then noticed the positive effect it was having
on both me and other people.
And now, I think it's just needed.
I think we just need to...
In a world that's full of overwhelm I think we should
be hearing about the kind people, you know?
The amazing things that happen in the world,
we just don't hear about.
Do you have any tips for digesting the realities
of the world because we can't ignore them,
what do you do?
I think notice the impact it's having on you for a start.
I think be mindful about how you're feeling when you read
a newspaper, when you've been scrolling through social media
or any of those things.
I think you've got to look hard for the good things
but they are there.
Yeah you've just got to look a little bit harder
than what's on the surface.
I Get on a feeder and it doesn't always make me
the happiest person.
I feel really informed and up to the minute but it's true.
It depletes my battery, my energy, my hope.
Yeah, that's the biggest thing
and that's what I've said from the beginning
of the newspaper, I want to give people hope
and I want people to realize that there are good things.
It's a really weird balance because obviously
whenever I've done any sort of press things,
you sort of get the people who are like, so naive
or you're sticking your head in the sand.
And I never want to try and cover up the bad
and pretend that the world is just full of sunshine
and rainbows because it isn't.
And I always try to acknowledge that.
What you're doing with your paper is you're giving
your lens of the world and we need this.
Emily, keep it up.
Let's stay the soul sisters that we are.
If I may interject myself into your life that way.
See, I told you it was going to get creepy.
Emily, thank you so much.
I'm so happy to know you.
Thank you news crew for bringing us together.
Can we please hang out again?
Definitely, thank you so much for having me.
I'm with you, let's keep up the good fight.
(audience applauding)
All right, moving on.
Okay, our next story,
this really spoke to me as the animal lover I am.
It turns out that a bunch of endangered species
are making a comeback and the good news network
has list of animals who were almost extinct
but are absolutely now thriving, like the four-eyed turtles.
Now they actually don't wear glasses because they would
slide right off, they don't have ears.
(audience laughs)
The World Wildlife Fund says that tigers are also making
a big comeback and that's in South Asia, Russia, China,
fantastic work tigers, yeah.
'Cause you always want to be on the good side of a tiger,
I know 'cause I greet one every morning
when I bring out the hairbrush to my daughter.
I almost lose my face and hand.
In more animal news, it's been reported that Mount Rainier
has had its first wolverine siting and over 100 years.
No, not that wolverine, I know. (whistles)
But a mama wolverine and her two baby Wolverines
were spotted prowling the park.
And I'll tell ya, a family of wolverines, I get you.
I see you, I avatar tale with you because I'm gonna show you
a picture that I show to people when I'm trying
to describe the mother I am with my children.
I'm a Doberman and protective, you feel me?
(audience laughing)
All right.
So here at the news we'd like to say a big welcome back
to all the endangered species, we missed you.
Moving on, this study is about social media,
the feeder we're all on and guess what?
There's some good news.
A study from Michigan State University said social media
can actually promote happiness as long as you interact
with it and you don't just doom scroll #doomscroll, #stop.
So just like in real life,
we should all foster a sense of community.
And that includes me.
I'm committed to spreading happiness all the time,
across all the shows channels,
and we're gonna even kick it up a notch.
So go to Drew Barrymore @drewbarrymoretv
and interact with us and we'll interact with you.
And then we'll all be happy because it's science baby.
(audience laughs)
Ha! you know?
One thing that really does mean everything to me here
at this news desk is to try and connect with people
and sometimes telling the stories around the world
and other people's stories is a way that you and I
as strangers can come together and know that something
positive is happening in the world.
That life is worth living.
The good things are happening.
And to me, that's as newsworthy as any news
you'll get today.
(upbeat music)